thank you very much for the introduction
so yeah um also i would like to say
thanks everyone to the volunteers uh the
organizers and focus for bringing pi
data london back after like a two years
break so actually i i just said like in
outside i'm at lunch i'm in basically my
happy place having a talk meeting new
random people without scheduling things
so it's i learned so much already and
was really great to reconnect to the
community
so uh i will be talking about lessons
learned in the field when consulting and
implementing data-driven
um
projects and bringing ai into place in
enterprises and small and medium
medium sized enterprises and you
probably don't know that like the small
and medium enterprises with like 500
5000 people employees they're like
backbone of the german
economy so we rarely have like really
huge enterprises than compared to the us
so there yeah
so uh we have like also big customers
like medium small size customers and i
would like to share some
lessons learned in the field some
practices of course this is the a little
biased on my experience this is the best
i can offer but i hope i can bring some
extra value
to the table for everyone so let me
start off
who has ever heard about the cooling
house experiment
no one
okay seems from the book this i didn't
find in english translations one of my
favorite books it's like the strategy of
uh
things going wrong about human logic and
behavior it's it's a book by dietrich
sterner he's a professor of theoretical
psychology psychology and he examines
human behavior
when making decisions in complex
situations and i think this is basically
the place we're in when we try
to make change and innovation happen
if there's more than three four five
people involved if it's more like an
organization or a bigger team so the
cooling house experiment is basically
the following you are the manager of a
supermarket
the automatically regulated temperature
control is broken and you cannot get it
fixed
until tomorrow so basically you have to
regulate it
by hand and you have to basically hit
four
degrees celsius and you have like these
minus and plus buttons to um regulate
temperature
and uh yeah that's it um and
it's like a simple task and you
basically have to hit exactly
four degrees celsius
and um it's a computer simulation so
it's not no no food was wasted during
the experiment it was a computer
simulation and
this is what actually happens
so
when we try to
turn like like to fix the temperature
humans tend to maximize
cooling or heating
or turn off
when you hit 40 degrees
and what can we learn about this from
from this
the temperature does not work like we
expect it's a complex problem like this
is basically how temperature behaves
it's not just like oh i'm 40 degrees
stop everything and these days it's it's
going still like going into another
direction there's many factors like the
food
air like there's so many factors
involved
so basically ev everybody was failing
totally failing and
actually it ended up
participants basically said this is not
the experiment this is about something
totally different you're fooling me
they're really getting angry or they
tried numbers with lucky numbers even
numbers magic on it was quite
odd and what can we learn from that
because
if you look at companies
companies are complex systems as
management there's the departments
there's a product owner there's eight
eye development i.t operations
and of course all the other departments
like hr and wow so and everybody's
talking to each other also for change in
innovation and um i don't know about you
but if i'm at clients i very often
discover
they talk all the time and constantly
plans are changing and shifting but not
not not necessarily for the better so if
you have experience like this or try to
learn what can be done better or what
shouldn't be done um i hope you will
enjoy this talk i'm alexander hendorf
i'm partner and founder of the boutique
consultancy kernig's week koenigsberg
we're very dedicated to the community we
run pi data frankfurt pi data southwest
uh we're five years community sponsor um
of the picond in pi data berlin and this
is basically if i'm
this is like the conference like we just
had last year the colleague of mine we
like heading off after corona in april
again and our motto is
transform to work smarter so we're not
like maybe many other consultants we're
basically there to enable our clients
and our claim is
the ingredients for innovation are
strategy means skills culture
and patience as well
and innovation
is complex so
and to solve complex
we basically need culture you cannot
make rules and regulate
everything to
as a complex human system to work you
need to establish a culture
who attended tania's keynote this
morning it was like
many years so you beyond this morning i
think it was a great keynote and we
learned a lot about like tech social um
systems and this is very similar here
it's basically the same same uh problem
so um
for example like people start okay we
need to innovate let's
do scrum and
change so there's like a saying change
is constant let's go work agile and
there's like for example one thing teams
and flat hierarchies it's like an
awesome concept everybody's immediately
on same page flat hierarchies accessible
management
um so
the idea is everybody's working together
hybrid teams we work agile we use chrome
um we have ratros to constantly improve
working on the product working together
and basically
fixing all the things all the time which
sounds like a really good plan doesn't
it
reality check says i'm not saying it's a
good concept but you also need to know
when to stop changing things because
there's a saying in germany or i think
it's also the same age never change a
running system so for example there's
rituals every three weeks
and
to be honest throw an idea fro ask
engineers for a problem and they always
throw your problems back
so and and and and there's and everybody
in this needs to so okay i need to add
some value so i need to find something
from the retro so we can change and
innovate because they need to report
something back to other management and
my best advice is a stop when
everything's go smoothly just like stop
changing things
if the team has found the rhythm and
everything's like working it's just like
fine and just like enjoy everything is
working on track
and of course very
underestimated is like how long change
of human routines actually takes it's
you need like professionals also to help
change you need to give everybody time
because like many people are working in
the company we come in they are there
for like 10 years they have established
routines they have established social
networks they have established behavior
so that's for example very often we team
up with another consultancy we and they
are actually psychologists and they have
a totally different angle on looking at
things and also helping to qualify who
is actually able to change who is a good
leader for the future and and what we're
looking for for flat and accessible and
everything and um and also they also can
test it and basically bring also some
evidence to the table and not just like
good guesses
um
so yeah so change needs time it needs
room to breathe and of course it also
needs discipline and reminders because
humans we tend to fall back in all in
established routines especially when
we're busy because when we're busy we
don't really think we're not as mindful
we just need to get things done and this
is why um this is actually way more work
than everybody expects and so
one thing is of course change needs time
but changes content but also changes not
a purpose in itself
so this is one part of culture apart
from open communication
transparency of decisions contribution
like a healthy culture like asking
questions so i always like asked if
clients ask me what's like a healthy
culture yeah go to a pi data conference
or any python conference
the community has switched there are no
stupid questions you can ask any
questions so and this is really good and
this is what you should establish in
your company as well
also
many i think we all know that or most of
you in the room will know that how do
you
actually get ai into your company or let
me rephrase the company how to buy ai in
2022
so let me demonstrate like a totally
different angle i like the more like
management angle in many companies
when they hear about ai they read about
ai in the newspapers they read about
startups um they do interviews and
everybody's of course
exaggerating so and or having these good
ideas for example like i just somebody
threw like a newspaper from from
and like one of the major german
newspapers frankfurter eigenminer
through like oh yeah ai now there's like
beth beethoven's 10th symphony ai finish
that
what do you think about this and i said
ah yeah well i'm really sorry but we
really have to deal with it beethoven is
dead and the 10th symphony will never be
finished it's and and for just like for
an example because of course i like the
idea i like ai is trying this so i think
it's still a funny project but it's not
a serious project because if we know a
little about beethoven beethoven's ninth
symphony is the only symphony having
like the chorus was actually like the
european hymn
so
if we just trained ai with the first
eight symphonies the ninth symphony
would have never been like this
magnificent including the choir
so um
ai can just like as you probably know
repeat what we have before in the data
and not be really creative but people
are not aware of it of course they lead
newspapers they lead high levels
um they
they read a lot of stuff so
um recently i met an old friend
at the train station and she said oh i'm
changing roles i'm in management on c
level
and and she asked me hey what are you
doing and yeah we founded boutique
consultancy koenigs week we do data and
ai and innovation and she and she just
replied oh yes in my new position i have
to buy ai as well
and and she's a great person like yeah
and i thought i just like had this
picture how do you imagine to buy ai is
it like cut
pace so
we of course many people think it's just
like another piece of software you can
buy
so and uh
it's it's it's part of something you
just order yeah so but i i say actually
this is a big misperspection because you
cannot buy it we have to build it
um and many people are not aware it's
not something you can buy of course
there are some ai services
speech translation stuff hey other
people have solved it already this is a
commodity service you don't need to
build it yourself but if you really want
to make the most
in in your market or your for your
domain and you need custom ai and you
cannot buy custom ai anywhere you
basically have to build it and you have
to
establish everything you need for
building ai which is culture has already
covered
data ai centric data at best um you need
resources skills means expertise
experience
and and a plan to make it happen also
we'd like to have the right way of
thinking um like an end-to-end thinking
and this brings me to a technical
example because what we very often see
people build prototypes
let's build ai
somebody is there and let's do ai great
very often working student
activist github all this
so this brings me to the lighthouse
problem so what's the lighthouse problem
the lighthouse problem is there's a
prototype in place a proof of concept um
driven by a single person or a group
which is
just like very um engaged
um
it's based on open source and blog posts
and it produces results in a very
reasonable time and really fast and
stakeholders are impressed so
if you just put yourself in the shoes of
the stakeholders how would you react oh
hello wunderkind
great we have ai basically solved and
here hey what about doing this if this
project a this looks amazing just more
do more yeah yeah great i want to do
more and basically it ends up like
adding more and more and more things and
nobody's basically always working only
on one machine it's not production ready
it's probably not software like real
good code and stuff but everybody
and suddenly everything falls apart and
people wonder
hey what had happened yeah because like
everybody's just like pushing for
results like uh there's no test there's
no documentation uh
there is it's not scalable it's not
maintainable probably the person who
built it left after like three months of
doing an internship um so
uh don't get me wrong i i love
prototyping and proof of concepts but
it's very important when to stop
and when to move forward and to take
things seriously or just leave it as is
so what happens with codebase is created
like this
recycle thrash can we cure it what's
your guess
huh right in the middle right in the
middle you say trash anybody in for
recycling
recycling oh dude who says you can cure
it
on okay
um
let me just show you a picture a
colleague of mine drew after he did code
review of one of these projects
uh yes he was just like collecting and
basically he was basically i i went
insane like there's so many things in
there that don't make sense they are
also not contributing to the project
they are just like adding okay we always
wanted to try something like this but
it's not really core value and actually
yes it ended up like this it ended up in
the trash it was completely rebuilt it
was not
it was not worth to refactor so of
course the best practice is have good
ideas try it out but know when to stop
yeah and know when you have to find
allies and the resources to make it
really happen
and also my call to all other
stakeholders have patience and don't
just walk by and be impressed on support
with resources and backing of those
projects of course they can add extra
value
so yeah
so basically
lighthouses is it's not a strategy
it's just like a bunch of new silos and
everybody should be aware like data
silos are one of the biggest problem in
enterprises there's so many data silos
nobody knows so the question we ask is
do we have a strategy or just like a
bunch of ideas because this brings me
also like to the next question um
is
going data-driven part of your corporate
strategy
or are you just like
want to try things out so basically if
it's yes
continue talk if you say no it's not
part of our long-term corporate strategy
you're saying hey no bye-bye
because
you really need nowadays you need to
really have the strategy
established otherwise time is just like
running the way the world is not waiting
for you and
many companies and most corporates have
waited too long already
so know what so of course
there's commodity services specialists
but market leaders as a market leader in
your domain you need to establish your
own
ai machine learning data driven services
very often like 70 percent is this
analytics getting the data in the right
right on formats offering analytics as
well this is all part of the process and
and the first step to establish a common
understanding is to see if everything
aligns do you have a strategy what's
your long-term plan and basically what
do you have in place and very often yeah
we did like a survey we did like these
lighthouses we have we have already we
did ai already and they say no this is
not
really um
how things should should be um
accomplished so basically our approach
is
to
ask should data follow ai
so basically we have this idea about ai
we always wanted to do something with
natural language processing for example
so people start to dig for data in the
company to do that so
and i think this is a questionable
approach because i strongly believe ai
should follow data so what's the process
going data driven is actually to have a
data strategy yeah and this includes
first step to a data dictionary so
basically go to all the company the it
departments
people
working with data doing reports you
don't you don't believe how many data
just like flies in with emails and excel
sheets which is very valuable
and you basically have to take time and
and and ask people okay what do you have
what do you work on because very often
people forget the data which is they
work most on they're just like so in
their routines they even realize it's
data anymore so just take some take it
digitally then qualify like
now we have the map this is the data we
have in place at the company and then
qualify which data is suitable what do
we need to do to access it and and
basically do like a top three top five
list what
what is there and based on that
in combination okay what's the domain
what's the business value identify
suitable ai technologies to work with
and of course putting the value for the
the company first so or like expertise
whatever there is in place and there's
always like crazy a lot of things you
find nobody's aware
based on that
decide
which infrastructure do we need so of
course we don't know go cloud first and
then look for data and i later so of
course also
look what do we have in place what do we
actually require
um
of course this is looks like really
simple of course everybody who works at
if you know this is like super complex
so uh but our approaches this is like
one example reference architecture we
just show to our clients say okay
there's like all your data sources and
you can do basically anything from
machines from your databases from your
sap system whatever and you put it in a
data lake oh by the way the data lake is
just like
a concept in mind so it's not a real
lake you put all your data in and you
get it out so and once you have data
accessible in your data and you don't
need to finish first filling up the lake
as soon as stuff there we have a data
hub we have apis with all the governance
processes and from there oh sorry it's
in german but i think you can follow so
we can have the data accessible for just
for statistics and analytics we can run
um
prediction models and we can also just
like have like classical bi tools
connected to that for like stuff because
not everything needs ai there so but the
main message is just that it's not about
the data lake it's not about the data
assist this is basically
you need to have the ability to
experiment so this is the major finding
because people very often forget to
think oh yeah google's so great yeah
google has a great
huge research department but last time i
checked they also built a lot of ai and
a lot of models
seems only like five percent of the
stuff that works in research actually
qualifies for production as well and of
course but these five percent they are
just like really they scale well they
bring a lot of extra value and very
often people don't get it you cannot
just like oh i need a prediction model
for that and it of course it will work
because it's not software that works we
are still
in an exploratory space
we can bring extra value inside but we
cannot guarantee we will build a
functional model for this
or that or like something specific so we
need to have flexibility and basically
every project people throw us ideas we
would like to accomplish that and we
said we're very sorry like especially
language processing is my my favorites
because like people okay we want a
knowledge graph oh you're sorry your
data set is not
it's not large enough there's no
knowledge graph actually building we
just have like trivial stuff there but
i think the important thing is to make
new suggestions and start a new
experiment what about
looking into entities what looking into
clustering your documents because
there's tons of documents and you were
like looking into key clauses in
contracts for example like there could
be penalties or with dates and stuff and
it's just like stuck there because
there's a lot of data just like in text
documents or contracts hidden
which no it's they're not in one in any
database nobody's really monitoring them
and especially for example in the
building um industry this can require
become quite expensive if you miss
deadlines or
stuff so
of course so the key
people have to learn and this is
something quite new if you're just like
corporate and you buy things and you buy
software no you don't buy so if you just
sign up the budget other people buying
software
so
with your quantity you have really say
okay we have to experiment to bring the
extra value to the table and uh making
ai happen
so
this
brings me already to the end of this
talk so basically these are key pillars
of ingredients of innovations not all of
them
so but basically we have to buy they
cannot buy it you have to build it and
if you like this talk or if you around
if you know friends
of course we also like i'm also looking
for new team members so
and just like this is my linkedin just
dm me directly if you're interested i
also like to work with free answers but
we um looking at many clients i always
think this is not how i ever will become
a screening company so yes why we i
killed hr and we're doing it ourselves
anymore again because i know best who i
need for my team for example so it is
always like seeing anti-patterns can
also help you to improve yourself
as a company so i hope you enjoyed this
talk and
yeah
then happy to answer questions
[Applause]
um i wonder what you think of things
like uh worldly mapping as a way to
give some structure to this kind of
what's what's innovation versus what's
kind of off the shelf that kind of thing
oh yeah uh of course
that's
this it's always important to do an
analysis
like very often um property software can
be still the better choice especially if
you look at small and middle-sized
enterprises they are sometimes they're
world market leaders they're like
germany are called hidden champions and
but they are sometimes really remote and
there's basically
it won't be possible to really find
recruit talent so there basically are
two options
you go to a bigger city and build a lab
and outsource an office there or you go
for if you don't have the people to do
all the fancy stuff you basically have
to settle for some good propriety system
and sometimes
um
there are also good solutions um to to
to solve yeah to to to address the
problem so i'm uh i think my belief is
like i'm uh not everything has to be
open source of course everything should
be open so
sometimes like i think that the right
mix is the right answer because we don't
need to reinvent the wheel for
everything
hello i was looking on your portfolio
and i have seen that you have companies
from multiple verticals
and i was wondering if you can give us
some examples of successful
ai projects and also what about sme do
you see also the same drive
on adopting ai i didn't hear it quite
well so
so
the other question was about smbs
do you see also them uh adopting ai as
enterprise or
yeah yeah like it's a mixture like it's
always like right it's like large
enterprises like companies you everybody
knows are all around the world and like
companies you've never heard of like
it's and they of course they have like
different rhythms they have different
structures um
just like from uh
depending on their size and and culture
um
was that your question or do we do
different approaches there
the first question was about uh some
examples from your portfolio because
i've seen that you have okay yes
different verticals like one is of
course we we uh
we go there and
uh help
in ongoing projects to establish
platforms like um team up with employees
there like to uh in terms of like okay
what's a good architecture where should
you move or what which technologies in
open source are suitable for you what do
you need to address in which order
help people like because there's also
like many people migrating from other
programming languages like help them
okay
migrate to python
or or not this is not always working
sometimes people just leave because like
there's jobs in every programming
language available um at large
um this one's like ongoing like helping
long-term strategy building new
platforms also sometimes like splitting
like the
platforms they've built themselves in
the past reinvent a new one outsource
some stuff to the cloud
um
then there's other of course we do also
do um offsite's projects we basically
for example say okay there's like for
example like one one example is
oem people who build cars in southern
germany um
in the luxury segment they had like a
large
corpus of research data like
they're all their research of like 30
years and they said oh no they we cannot
read it we search is not good enough
what can we do with natural language
processing and this is something okay
let's help you to explore it um so we
built for them uh with open source
a tool to they can inspect the data and
we of course we qualified for example
the knowledge graph example was there
because we would like to have a
knowledge because i'm sorry it's not
working of course we can get data
outside but this is not addressing your
problem because you don't need we're not
rebuilding some like something to
explain the world we have to address
stuff just in your corpus but then we
said okay you can have summaries we can
have cluster clustering worked really
well and
extracting entities from the corpus and
this gave them a completely new
perspective for example there it was
more interesting
what have we done on research for
example on batteries in the past
and then you basically have everything
related to batteries and then sometimes
also like niche
research which was forgotten because for
them it brings a lot of extra value
because think about it you you do
research and you do research with
material and a lot of manpower trying
things out and this can easily cost
millions and a lot of work time and so
for them it's a real value to say oh no
we've done this before like 15 years ago
and we can re build on these results or
just realize okay no we don't we or like
basically changed the plan and said okay
we don't really believe anymore we
should follow along with this approach
this is another example
so
yeah so it's
any more questions
alex i had a question for you
i know you brought this thing about
retros yeah i've seen no i've seen that
you know agile
was set up as a
process or methodology to reduce risk or
improve repeatability right but it seems
to be a religion and people seem to get
lost
so yeah people seem to yeah
now what are your thoughts on that my
thoughts is actually we need you we need
to collect data
and have look on what's happening in a
larger perspective because like thinking
in like cycles of three weeks it's just
like wrong so yeah so
basically you always have to look really
back what was the situation half a year
ago what is the situation now and then
think about it so sometimes i really
wish sometimes the retro would just like
skip because there's nothing to to say
everybody's just like unhappy and
and
and uh but yeah it's just like i i
i think it's very difficult because like
of course
um agile and scrum is all about rituals
and keeping like the rhythm and
everything but yeah if there's nothing
to improve so what should we do i mean
we should just like hey let's decide
let's skip the ratio there's nothing to
do because we also there's
there's a larger team of like 10 people
10 15 people sometimes just think
there's like two hour retro this is like
uh 30 hours um this is like uh yeah
that's multiple work days we just throw
in just like spending time with each
other
and there's other things to do most most
of the time so nobody's bored
anyway so yeah so i think um we have to
we could also be critical and open and
also i'm addressing these things openly
i think we don't really
need this we have it so and and and what
the other thing i learned actually is
because um i don't know about you but i
always had like the expression like
engineers software developers we tend to
overthink and over optimize but i had to
realize basically everybody else is
doing it as well like
i was i was quite surprised
so if there's no problem people look for
problem everybody just of course brings
tries to bring extra value which is like
which is great i mean i don't
for me it's important i'm not
complaining of the persons there because
they all everybody's like really engaged
and trying to do their job but sometimes
it's just that good to do the better
thing is just to say no it's there's
nothing to do it's great um but it's of
course you have nothing to report to
somebody else it's
yeah
a follow-on question so have you ever
seen velocity measured
oh yes teams
um
yeah it's a very difficult question
actually um because um
the truth is um
there's lack of statistical knowledge
involved and there's like
velocities master measured and actually
if you look at there's too many data
points missing
um because
there's like okay you always have like i
think
velocity and everything is a good
estimate yeah and it's i think it's a
good thing to do but sometimes people
try to dig too deep into data and just
like no sorry people were like sick this
is not being accounted for so basically
you need like full surveillance who's
working when what on which project who
was sick when there's like so much data
missing
and there's it's it's just like yeah you
just have to accept it it's like
okay
i think we're on the right track it's a
good estimate but that's it and that's
all good but sometimes people try to
find things which are just not there and
also especially data scientists if you
look at the data scientists in the team
calls the you see they roll their eyes
because of course like
statistically this is not solid at all
but it's yeah so but i'm trying to help
also like to addre like in one-on-one
conversations i'm also addressing this i
mean this is my job also to put the
fingers somewhere okay this is something
you should
consider yeah so um because everybody's
trying to contribute so it's not not a
bad thing per se
so you said you don't use uh you don't
do retros
you said you don't do retros in your
teams
oh yeah we do but okay basically
basically not as it's it's not a
self-purpose so
if we see okay there's nothing to
address then just like stop it and then
it's fine of course retros are important
but if you like think about rituals
every three weeks
in some teams they are just like okay
we're happy we're moving on everything's
fine
just skip it so that's i think and this
is not basically built in the process
and uh
yeah or do do other things in retros
like team building have coffee chat
about everything else but not try to
find problems uh that's where no
problems are
uh are we all in time
yeah um so okay on the back of that yeah
um so okay less lit
less retros but what about the rest of
screamer agile how how closely
screaming or how closely do you work
within those frameworks like what do you
do how is your we do very many of our
clients they work like that and of
course we integrate into teams but i'm
also i'm my job is also to observe and
to give feedback and of course also i
talked to
people there working there and they say
okay there's nothing really to discuss
yeah especially if you try to
look into numbers which they are not
which are not solid yeah so
don't get me wrong i think this is a
very good process working agile working
scrum like this but it should be not
dogmatic by some
some rituals are like just like okay we
have to do this we have to do this and
yeah and basically oh let's be adults
and just like skip if everything's fine
um and it's it's i think that's really
easy to graph is that you the team has
something to address of it's just
throwing like tiny things okay
no
i have this quest to try and figure out
how to to marry agile in data science
because obviously data science doesn't
go very well with agile in two weeks
prints so i was wondering yeah what was
your experience two weeks i think yeah
two weeks is
putting it out now i think like uh three
weeks prints it should be at least and
of course
uh i because i agree uh very much later
data science it's really hard like you
cannot basically say okay your results
have to do the user story and your data
science results have to be ready in like
three weeks i mean like we're working
experiments as i explained it's
experiments and sometimes we have
early results sometimes we have results
in time but very often
there are results but to validate the
results this needs time and this i agree
does is not a good fit to throw it like
into these like
three hour weeks blocks especially um
some um
sometimes there's also like a feedback
loop how many user stories have been
moved
it has to be explained why so it's not
just okay no it didn't finish okay let's
continue next print
startups can do that but like um
especially regulated um companies they
uh sometimes have to even report back or
like document why this has moved um
because
the
the the the framework is built they uh
there's something essential has to be
fixed so something like okay we cannot
trade we cannot send stuff of course
this is like the background but this is
also like so yeah
so sometimes it's better off to do this
and
move this out of like
exploratory data science stuff we try to
move out into like okay this is like an
explanation like more like um a story
which is to investigate something which
has not like a defined delivery result
so it's just like investigate and
after three weeks you can just like give
a report okay these are the findings
this is like the status and then just
like if you have to continue just do
another story and basically you
basically have the full story split into
multiple that's another thing you can do
just like form as a technical solution
the problem still
stays the same and the solution stays
the same and the the time needed stays
the same yeah
okay thank you
i had to follow one thing right so you
know agile all started to sort of have
repeatable processes and reduce the risk
but somehow it's become a religion right
and like
yeah it's been taken to the extreme so
you know things like velocity if you're
in a prototyping world where it's you
know you don't have a steady state it's
not worth measuring velocity right
because it's you're experimenting you're
changing but yeah somehow
you know these agile experts come in and
it's the same process but it's the big
picture is you reduce your risk of
delivery right
right i think
thanks alex